i would say Pakistan ought to be near
the top of the foreign policy heap it's
probably the most worrisome and
difficult foreign policy challenge or
national security challenge facing the
administration you've got I don't know
plus or minus a hundred nuclear weapons
you have the headquarters so to speak of
the the world's principal terrorist
organizations you've got a government
that is unable unwilling or both when it
comes to controlling its own territory
you've got a government that to some
extent is not a government it's not in
control of it itself what to add it all
up you've got a tremendous gap or
disparity between US interests on one
hand which are enormous and US influence
on the other hand which is quite limited
and anytime you have a gap between
interests and influence you're obviously
in an uncomfortable or dangerous
situation and that's where the u.s. is
with Pakistan it also holds the key to
some extent with Afghanistan so getting
the Pakistanis to deal with this growing
what you might call Taliban ization of
their society which is bad for
Pakistan's future as well as Afghanistan
is something we can edge but we can't
force and we can't do it for them so we
do the odd predator attack which to some
extent helps to some extent alienates
the society the real question is whether
we can build up relevant Pakistani
capabilities because most of their
military capabilities quite honestly are
irrelevant to the challenge they face
they're based upon some I think largely
non-existent Indian threat rather than
the real threats the Pakistanis face and
it's also not clear to me they have the
will there are large parts of the
Pakistani establishment that don't agree
that the Taliban represent an
existential threat to their country or
their society so I don't see the United
States doing in Pakistan anything like
it's doing in Afghanistan I don't see
any broad commitment of ground troops
this is a country of 175 million people
we're not going to do that but I can't
imagine a war of its necessity arising
in the context of Pakistani state
failure I can imagine a president the
United States
conceivably ordering special forces or
air strikes to deal with terrorists or I
can imagine a president the United
States ordering special forces in or air
strikes to deal with nuclear materials
so it's not inconceivable to me that
sometime during mr. Obama's presidency
be it for if it has eight years we could
see something of a discreet you might
call it war of necessity visa V Pakistan
a Pakistani government that rather than
growing is facing real economic problems
is going to be that much worse off in
dealing with its internal political and
security challenges
I don't see it I believe that the
Chinese are preoccupied with employment
with the success of their economy they
know they're an underdeveloped country I
don't believe the strategic culture of
China is also heavily I don't believe
it's a an imperialist global challenge I
don't believe the Chinese for example
are going to attack Taiwan because again
with the Chinese know they need are
literally decades of stability so they
can grow their economy they still have
hundreds of millions of people to move
from rural areas into urban areas they
know just how underdeveloped they are
now if you're asking me 50 years from
now 75 from yesterday couldn't mature
China take a different direction yeah I
can i can see that conceivably I'm not
predicting it but I can imagine it and
the one thing that worries me about
China's political trajectory is that is
what will motivate its people I worry
that the principal motive in China in
down the road again we're talking in
decades or longer here could be
nationalism and that would be unhealthy
and that's the reason that I believe
it's important that China gradually open
up politically that China can't simply
be a culture based on materialism I
don't believe socialism or communism are
going to be its motives so I do believe
it needs greater political participation
but if I were a US Defense planner a lot
of things would keep me up night night
so we've talked about some of them like
Pakistan like Afghanistan like a rock
like Iran like North Korea China would
not be on the top 10 of that list